قبل ذلك حظيت دعوه وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي
لتعليق تعديلات مقترحه على نظام القضائي
في اسرائيل بالعديد من الاصوات الداعمه
طبعا من داخل حزب الليكود الذي يتزعمه
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
وبالتالي قد تزيد هذه الدعوه من الضغوط
الحزبيه على نتانياهو وترفع احتمال تقلص
الاغلبيه البرلمانيه التي تحظى بها
الحكومه لكن مشاهدينا لماذا يصرنا تنياهو
على هذا التعديل بنظام القضائي سنعود
ونسرد القصه التي بدات قبل اسابيع فقط من
استلام نتنياهو للسلطه حين فصلت المحكمه
العليا حليف نتانياهو اريا درعي رئيس حزب
شاص المتشدد من منصبه وزيرا للداخليه
والصحه لادانته طبعا كما هو معلوم بقضايا
فساد وتهرب ضاربين سيما وان نتنياهو بذل
جهودا حثيثه لخلق ثغره قانونيه تلتف على
القانون الاسرائيلي يحول دون ان يتبوا
الملاحقون قضائيا المناصب الوزاريه الى ان
ذلك لم ينجح وفقا طبعا لاعلام اسرائيلي
الذي اضاف ان نتنياهو تعهد بمواصله السعي
لمواجهه القضاء التي من شانها ان تمنح
الكنيسه الاسرائيلي صلاحيات واسعه على
حساب القضاء طبعا وتشمل التعديلات
المقترحه الحد من المراقبه للتشريعات
الكنيست وسيطره الحكومه طبعا على تعينات
القضاه والغاء تدخل المحكمه العليا في
الاوامر التنفيذيه وبالتالي يمكن لهذه
التعديلات حال تم اقرارها ان تمهد الطريق
لعوده درع الى المناصب الوزاريه التي اقيل
منها ليس هذا فحسب بل ستساعد نتنياهو ايضا
في التخلص من قضايا الرشوه والاحتيال التي
تلاحقه وذلك بسبب ما تنطوي عليه من اضعاف
سلطات المدعي العام وكل هذا يعني طبعا منح
نتنياهو الحصانه الكامله من الم لاحقه
القانونيه الان ومستقبلا
[موسيقى]